what's broken
the dollar is broken because
the fed
no longer is able to control the
issuance of the dollar in any way when
you start to look at uh these assets how
much of uh price as a marketing
department i i think about that a lot
right like bitcoin is a decentralized
entity there is no ceo there's no board
of directors there's no marketing team
etc uh
the
price as you described brought you in
and then you learned about bitcoin you
learned about a lot of the stuff and
then you became kind of a long-term
participant in the market
is that what we should expect everyone
to come through from like a funnel
standpoint is price ends up being the
thing that attracts them and then they
kind of go down the rabbit hole get
converted into what i think people would
describe as a bitcoiner in the united
states yes okay you know it's it's it is
likely that
the price is what attracts people the
most in this country um
we have a country of entrepreneurs
and
a spirit of innovation in this country
and when you see something accelerating
in price
it draws attention but if we go to
different parts of the world latin
america and africa where the currency
regimes are disasters
they're not looking at price they're
looking at does it work
does it maintain value versus my own
currency which the answer is yes you
know when you're looking at turkey or
argentina something like that
so
we we do have to be conscious that
in different parts of the world the
reason to get involved in bitcoin is
different right i let's cite gladstein's
book title check your financial
privilege
in we do have privilege in this country
and it doesn't exist in a lot of parts
of the world and so we have to put our
feet in their shoes to think about why
they might be involved in bitcoin so i
have an argentinian friend
and i i've known him since 2012.
what he communicates to me is that the
culture in argentina of understanding
bitcoin is at another level versus the
western world because they're intimately
aware of currency collapse
hyperinflation and the things that we
tout as bitcoiners as
you know attractive things about the
network and the asset but
are we using bitcoin as americans to
escape
uh a currency collapse
not immediately
right that might be part of your thesis
over the next 10 20 years you might even
think it's coming over the next two
years in which i'd say you're wrong
about that the dollar's not collapsing
in two years
but
it's not the reason that americans are
getting involved is imminent currency
this threat is not imminent in the
united states whereas in other countries
argentina i think it's got 50 or more
you know annual inflation right and the
threat is present in the united states i
think that's why a lot of see i found
bitcoin through understanding the fed
and monetary policy and how it worked
not not after that's my that's my
background is studying the fed and
trading rates
so when i look at
the
monetary situation the fiscal situation
in the united states i see something
unsustainable over a long period i also
see something that's broken
but i don't see something that's
collapsing today what's broken
the dollar is broken because
the fed
no longer is able to control the
issuance of the dollar in any way first
of all the dollar is issued by
commercial banks mostly in this country
as well as in the euro dollar system
which is
dollars issued outside of the federal
reserve
banking system so you have
call it 15 trillion dollars of
dollars created outside the fed system
that they weren't aware of for most of
the beginning of it and then when it
broke in 2007
in august to 2007 when libor and fed
funds separated what we saw is that the
euro dollar system has a risk that is
materially different than the onshore
dollar system the fed recognized that
and they put a swap line on with the ecb
in december 2007 like four months after
the system broke and they've exercised
that swap line in 08 09 during the pigs
crisis
um during the pandemic etc so the dollar
system is broken because the dollar
exists in all these different forms
and the fed has basically had to say we
will bail out the different forms even
though we never approved of them that's
a broken system explain swap lines a
little bit okay so
when the ecb the european central bank
has banks in its jurisdiction that have
issued dollar deposits to their
customers let's just put it on deutsche
bank
so let's say deutsche bank has customers
that have dollar deposits and then
deutsche bank is going through some
trouble they need dollar liquidity the
market says no we're not going to lend
you dollars euro dollar market
uh you're shut off from it so where is
deutsche bank going to get the dollars
to stay liquid on their dollar balance
sheet
they're gonna get them from the ecb not
from the fed because the they're in
germany so they go to the ecb and they
say hey ecb can we borrow dollars
the ecb says okay but we don't have
dollars we're europe
so
they print euros
and then they post them as collateral to
the fed
and then the fed lends dollars to the
ecb
and then the ecb can lend those dollars
to deutsche bank so that's the swap line
it's a swap of euros for dollars
where europe just basically creates
euros
and then post them as collateral to
borrow dollars from the fed if one of
those two currencies uh strengthens
aggressively against the other or
depreciates aggressively against the
other uh does that break the swap line
are there issues there it doesn't really
because you know the the movement is not
material enough to these guys are not
borrowing on leverage they're borrowing
you know full amount so let's say you
borrow 100 million and then the currency
moves five percent against you you owe
105 million back to the european central
bank that's not to that's not going to
break anything absolutely and so when
you think about some of these issues um
is the central bank of the united states
and other countries they just have to
continue to take on
more debt they have to continue to
create more money
and it's pretty much just like a race to
see who can do it the least uh fast in
some way it is because if you think
about the way that you know united
states in 30 trillion of debt
and uh financial crisis you know every
two to five to ten years each time
another crisis happens the government
has to borrow trillions of dollars the
trillions of dollars that it has to
borrow isn't it immediately available in
the market in terms of the bar the
lending source so the fed comes in and
monetizes it the reason that the fed
does that and the reason that the
government does that first of all the
government does it because they don't
want to get voted out so it's easy to
just say here's the stimulus here's the
next stimulus we've seen that now 15
years straight uh non-stop stimulus then
the fed
looks at the inflation rate historically
not today but inflation rate at one
point something percent two percent and
in decline and they look at a declining
inflation rate as a danger zone for them
because when
prices go down a credit system starts to
collapse right credit needs expansion
because you always have you always have
to borrow
to
pay back your debt you know you have to
roll the debt so if deflation happens
it's the fed's number one fear
and so that's why they do qe that's why
they lower interest rates is because
they are they are fearful of deflation
and so they'll do anything they can to
prevent that and so in that way we have
to assume that
the policy from government and fed will
be stimulative now
looking at this year specifically i
think we're gonna have to wait
for the next stimulative episode to
begin i think that the fed views eight
percent inflation as maybe equally
dangerous so they have to keep going on
rate hikes i do not think we're going to
see qe anytime soon we're actually
seeing the opposite we're seeing qt the
fed is shrinking its balance sheet it's
raising interest rates so it's actually
strengthening the dollar
as an asset as a global asset relative
to other currencies and so we'll see
that and we we might see risk asset
weakness on the back of that
but i think the fed's most important
goal right now is bringing inflation
down